[Musique]
la montagne sa verticalité son altitude
ses températures parfois extrêmes la
rendent aussi majestueuse qu'un
prévisible la montagne est un milieu
abrasif c'est un monde dangereux on fait
face à la tyrannie du milieu la montagne
a toujours été un espace répulsif sauf
qu'aujourd'hui il devient stratégique et
depuis que l'homme se fait la guerre
c'est dénivelé ces lignes de crête et
ses sommets enneigées ont toujours
concentré l'attention des stratèges
militaires
point d'observation frontière naturelle
ou encore zone refuge du résistant de
l'insurgé cette géographie bien
particulière fait de la montagne un
milieu à part que l'homme en arme se
doit d'apprivoiser ou du moins de
maîtriser dans le combat montagne on a
deux ennemis l'espace naturel dans
lequel on combat et les nuits proprement
dit c'est aussi une façon de raisonner
le terrain de raisonner l'ennemi à la
fin des années 2000 on se rend compte
que plus la moitié des conflits dans le
monde en lui en zone de montagne
en France ils sont 8000 soldats
d'activés de réserves à être
spécialistes de combat en montagne rompu
relief et à l'évolution zone montagneuse
ces militaires n'ont cessé de mettre
leur savoir-faire au service des
opérations
[Musique]
au sol mais aussi dans les airs ils ont
à chaque fois du composé avec ce milieu
bien particulier pour partir à l'assaut
dans la montagne
du coup les gars là de ce que j'ai vu
sur les dernières descente donc dans
l'ensemble c'est vraiment pas mal
d'accord là en grosso modo on va dire un
jour et demi complet en station vous
avez atteint le niveau où vous êtes
capable de descendre d'une piste bleue
pour des gars qui avaient jamais ou
presque jamais ce qui avant
c'est déjà bien quoi là j'ai une section
de jeunes incorporés donc ils sont
arrivés en octobre 2022 donc là ils ont
fini la partie ce qu'on appelle FG donc
formation général initiale c'est une
formation initiale qui dure 10 semaines
et ensuite là pendant 5 semaines on fait
ce qu'on appelle la famille hiver donc
c'est la formation montagne hiver pour
les chasseurs alpins là comme on est là
vraiment au début pour apprendre à skier
on commence en station et après des dès
la fin de semaine on va commencer à
faire un peu de ski de randonnée et dès
la semaine prochaine à partir dans des
domaines hors-piste et là découvrir
vraiment ce que c'est
le ski de randonnée militaire
les débuts sont difficiles pour ces
jeunes engagés certains n'ont jamais
chaussé de ski tout juste incorporé ils
doivent apprendre à évoluer dans ce
milieu exigeant que la montagne c'est un
passage obligé pour tous les chasseurs
alpins
donc je me suis dit si les autres y
arrivent pourquoi pas moi au début c'est
pas facile c'est compliqué mais on est
là pour apprendre ça sert à ça le stage
néanmoins à deux semaines
d'apprentissage les progrès sont déjà
visibles mais si le ski de descente ne
constitue que la première étape l'enjeu
est de gravir Mons et sommets
[Applaudissements]
dans ma vie civile avant donc c'est que
du plaisir et on touche le cœur ça sera
le pain c'est la montagne c'est un
milieu très particulier qui est quand
même assez dur donc faut être habitué à
la fois au froid et au à la montée et
dans un second temps il y a de la
bienveillance parce qu'on doit tous être
très solidaire ils ont des autres pour
qu'on puisse tous aller au bout de
l'émission dans la montagne
ah ouais toujours pas ce stage de skieur
militaire de cinq semaines a pour
vocation d'enseigner les différentes
techniques d'évolution en saison
hivernale à cette jeune section
donc c'est le stage brevet skier
militaire qui est un stage donc
traditionnel chez chasseur alpin donc là
on fait deux semaines de ce qui
technique donc c'est du ski vraiment
alpin en station et ensuite à partir de
donc déjà aujourd'hui et la semaine
prochaine on va faire du de la peau de
phoque donc c'est ni plus ni moins que
le que le skin randonnée
et ça c'est dans un but ultime c'est de
finir le stage par brevet skieur
militaire donc c'est 1200 mètres de
dénivelé à faire en moins de 4h30 avec
l'arme
alors je suis en train d'installer mes
potes car là cet après-midi on va faire
un peu de ski de randonnée donc les pots
de phoques vont nous permettre de monter
la pompe de la montagne sans glisser et
pour monter c'est jeune stagiaires vont
se confronter à différents ateliers
monter en peau de phoque monter avec des
crampons un peu les couteaux ou ce qui
est ado le but est de maîtriser un panel
de savoir-faire pour pallier à toute
situation en montagne l'hiver
on se casse la petite plateforme on
s'équilibre avec les bâtons ensuite
d'accord
le ski intérieur
ou bien le placer et pareil on le
stabilise d'accord
et ensuite là c'est pas trop raide c'est
un spatule du style qui est en aval
d'accord elle fait le tour du talon
comme ça d'accord
tu mets bien ta chaussure dans l'axe des
fixations
nouvelles pour moi évidemment ce que
c'est quelque chose que je ne pratiquais
pas avant ça demande un petit peu de de
participer il faut connaître le matériel
il faut savoir lancer des correctement
et surtout il faut être rapide dans les
transitions parce que on a différents
matériels suivant les situations de
monter donc il faut savoir changer
rapidement de matériel donc ça demande
de du temps d'apprentissage et également
de l'investissement personnel
mais la route est encore longue avant de
devenir un chasseur alpin chevronné en
complément du brevet de skieur militaire
ces jeunes stagiaires apprendront aussi
à se déplacer en montagne l'été
ce sera l'objet d'un autre stage celui
d'alpiniste militaire au programme
escalade et ascension en hiver comme en
été ils ont acquis les bases de
l'évolution en montagne
dénominateur commun c'est la capacité à
apprivoiser le milieu ou à maîtriser les
conséquences ou les contraintes du
milieu et donc le brevet de cire
militaire le brevet d'alpinistes
militaire ce sont des brevets que nous
passons en début de formation c'est la
première marche des compétences pour un
soldat de montagne
pour les pilotes d'hélicoptère aussi la
montagne est un milieu à part
et c'est ici au cœur des Pyrénées dans
un centre unique en France le centre de
vol en montagne que les jeunes pilotes
aussi bien de l'armée de terre de
l'Armée de l'Air d'espace de la Marine
nationale que de la gendarmerie
nationale viennent se former sur leur
dis-moi de formation initiale il passe
15 jours à évoluer dans les reliefs
pour Edwin le volant montagne est une
découverte depuis son arrivée au centre
il y a une semaine ils vole tous les
jours un objectif savoir poser son
hélicoptère en montagne et en toute
sécurité le vent a des effets un peu
spécifiques en montagne en fonction du
relief il va porter plus ou moins la
machine ou la rabattre vers les vers les
reliefs et donc en fait on aura un souci
permanent de la sécurité en déterminant
des zones de dégagement pour pour éviter
en fait de percuter le relief donc on va
partir sur le premier point qu'on
traitera certainement une ligne de crête
d'accord perché à 1300 mètres d'altitude
et à proximité de 11 zones
d'entraînement le Centre de Vol au
montagne et l'endroit idéal pour
appréhender ce milieu vertical
au total 4000 mouvements d'hélicoptère
sont enregistrés ici chaque année
au centre de vol en montagne la
formation était prouvante sous l'oeil
attentif du capitaine Laurent pilote
depuis 24 ans Edwin entame son septième
vol en montagne à bord de cet
hélicoptère EC 120 militarisé
faire
une pour de rencontres des effets du
vent sur la zone de manière précise et
ensuite on va développer donc la méthode
de résultats pour la prochaine décollage
afin d'aller se poser sur un point qu'on
aura définir a priori un fondé et sans
doute un peu plus haut en ligne de Crète
en appliquant une méthode spécifique de
raisonnement d'approche et de décollage
il devra analyser son environnement pour
identifier la meilleure zone de poser
possible
[Musique]
mais au-delà de voler sans les repères
habituels comme l'horizon et de composer
avec la météorologie et l'aérologie
spécifique liée à la montagne l'enjeu de
cette formation est d'appréhender ce que
les pilotes appellent la limite de
puissance en résumé la capacité de
portage de l'appareil et du fait de
l'altitude et de la densité de l'air les
Pyrénées constituent un terrain
d'entraînement des plus propices pour
appréhender les limites de l'appareil
qui n'est pas facile donc il faut
meilleures conditions pour y arriver sa
formation au centre de volontagnes
accomplie Edwin rejoindra sa base école
de l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
située à Dax pour terminer sa formation
initiale par la suite il se spécialisera
et sera amené à piloter sur hélicoptère
de manœuvre ou hélicoptère d'attaque en
opération extérieure opération sur des
terrains rarement privés de relief et
d'altitude
la troisième dimension pour relancer la
manœuvre en montagne c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est qui est essentiel
on peut s'en passer mais mais ça donne
une plus-value énorme nous l'avons
utilisé d'où l'utilisons nous sommes en
relation constante avec avec ton
camarade de la latte avec laquelle on a
on a combattu en particulier au Sahel et
donc cette cette capacité à appréhender
l'aérologie la complexité
de ce milieu là en fait ça nous donne
des
une un vocabulaire et une grammaire que
nous partageons avec nos camarades de la
latte
[Musique]
savoir ce qui est ou encore voler en
montagne ne suffisent pas pour combattre
dans ce milieu particulier et c'est ici
à Chamonix dans le temple de l'alpinisme
français à l'école militaire de haute
montagne que les cadres des soldats de
montagne viennent se former encore et
toujours et c'est même un passage obligé
ils sont 650 stagiaires à venir éprouver
ici la montagne chaque année en été
comme en hiver donc du coup aujourd'hui
petite phase synthèse sur trois jours
trois jours de déplacement et demi de
stationnement
tout ça pour vous faire acquérir les
acteurs réflexes du grand froid des
techniques grand froides ça va nous
permettre d'utiliser comme si vous étiez
en opérationnel les poules cas et les
temps de grand froid et les réchauds
grands froid donc un petit déplacement
là de 400 mètres jusqu'au point de
stationnement et demain une course en
montagne jusqu'à la tête de Boston
l'objectif à atteindre dans ces
conditions éprouvantes est un sommet
perché à 2300 mètres d'altitude pour
mener à bien cette mission il traque des
poules cas c'est traîneaux pesant auprès
de 70 kg contenant vivre et tente pour
la nuit
en large dans le virage faute dans le
raid pour le capitaine Benoît c'est une
première ça se passe bien on avance pas
une bonne vitesse donc le poids de la
pulca est soutenable avant de devenir
commandant d'unité au sein de son
régiment il doit effectuer ce stage de 6
semaines pour devenir chef de
détachement en haute montagne
c'est-à-dire être formé à emmener une
section en altitude cette formation de
chef de détachement haute montagne hiver
pour la saison actuelle nous permet
d'emmener avec un très grand degré
d'autonomie une troupe de chasseurs
alpin avec déjà des de la formation donc
ça nous permet deux choses soit déjà de
les former initialement soit de les
emmener lors de différentes sorties soit
de sortie purement technique soit
également des sorties tactiques et de
mettre en oeuvre des techniques qu'on a
pu apprendre dans du grand froid dans
les différentes saisons
mais avant d'atteindre la tête de Boston
le groupe péalte pour la nuit là on est
arrivé dans la zone de stationnement
donc on attend le détachement qui arrive
avec les avec les pulcas ils sont juste
là derrière nous le but est de trouver
la zone la plus plate possible de
manière à pouvoir monter une tente Metz
pour manger le soir et des tentes
individuelles pour que les trinome
dorment dans les tentes
[Applaudissements]
comme aujourd'hui c'est le souci de
l'humain aujourd'hui il neige il fait
pas très très froid mais de manière à ce
qu'on puisse se mettre à l'abri qu'on
soit le moins mouillé possible donc dans
un premier temps c'est l'humain et
ensuite on va monter les tentes et c'est
vraiment le matériel après
voilà on a quand même le grand confort
vous avez vu en tout cas c'est les deux
200 mètres heures maximum ok donc le
chef de d'être faut bien qu'il pense à
faire tourner les tireurs de les
tracteurs les tracteurs tireurs depuis
le cas et surtout là on a
60 cm de neige est tombé pendant la nuit
et les vents avoisine les 70 km/h le
jour de cet exercice n'a pas été choisi
au hasard par les instructeurs bien au
contraire mais pas question pour les
stagiaires de renoncer pour autant alors
pourquoi c'est nécessaire parce que déjà
la montagne est difficile donc il faut
avoir de l'expérience et connaître
toutes les techniques de manière à
pouvoir les appliquer au combat par la
suite parce que les conflits de demain
seront peut-être dans des zones
montagnases ou des zones enneigées ou
des zones grands froid polaires comme ça
va pouvoir arriver donc nous c'est des
techniques
et des savoir-faire qu'on apprend à nos
stagiaires de manière à avoir cette
veille opérationnelle pour que les
stagiaires puissent jeunesse pas mais un
jour peut-être s'en servir en zone grand
froid zone polaire ou zone montagne d'un
point de vue tactique et combat la
montagne c'est de l'opérationnel on l'a
bien vu cette semaine puisque en fait on
est constamment confronté au danger donc
le danger en montagne ce sera en tout
cas de manière quand on fait de la
mentalité technique comme ça sera pas
l'ennemi mais c'est le milieu qui est
extrêmement difficile et un mauvais
choix peut conduire assez rapidement à
une situation hasardeuse voir
catastrophique donc c'est c'est
effectivement une situation très
opérationnelle qui nous aide nous à
prendre des décisions très importantes
dans un cadre engagé et engageant et qui
en fait vont avoir un impact immédiat
sur le succès de la mission ou non je
pense qu'un soldat qui n'est pas
entraîné à ce milieu particulier face à
l'agression climatique face au défi
physique face à la verticalité peut
avoir tendance à se concentrer sur sa
propre survie et négliger finalement les
impératifs du combat c'est pour ça que
nous nous entraînons c'est pour dépasser
des passer ce stade et donc ça nous met
en bonne position pour intervenir sur
des théâtres froids ou par exemple le
nord de l'Europe ou pourquoi pas
l'Arctique si un jour il y avait un
besoin d'intervenir dans cette zone
savoir-faire spécifique au milieu
montagneux sont le fruit d'une longue
tradition militaire
il faudra attendre plus d'un demi-siècle
pour que les premières instructions
spécialisées au combat en montagne
voient le jour le premier texte vraiment
officiel est un manuel d'alpinisme
destiné aux militaires et un an après il
y aura la première instruction
provisoire pour les opérations des
grandes unités en montagne on est en
1932 c'est relativement récent mais
c'est en même temps très tôt si on
compare la montagne par rapport à
d'autres types d'espaces comme la ville
ou encore la jungle
et c'est une première en rapport avec un
espace spécifique les instructions au
combat en milieu désertiques forestiers
et urbain n'apparaîtront elle qu'après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est que
pour la première fois on voit un milieu
être pris à part par rapport à ce que
l'on pense de l'art de la guerre donc la
montagne suscite un certain intérêts
tout au long du 19e siècle il faut
attendre l'après Première Guerre
mondiale pour voir justement la pensée
militaire évoluer mais aussi le métier
militaire évolué par rapport à ce type
de milieu depuis le combat en montagne
n'a cessé d'évoluer au fil des
opérations de la résistance du plateau
des Glières en 1944 au massif des
ifugats au Mali la Bosnie-Herzégovine
dans les années 90 le Kosovo en 1999
également l'Afghanistan que vous avez
cité le Mali et l'Afrique saélienne une
manière générale dans les années 2000
jusqu'aux années 2020 lorsque l'on
regarde une carte des conflits à la fin
du des années 2000 se rend compte que
plus la moitié des conflits dans le
monde on lui en zone de montagne et dans
ces confrontations une constante
apparaît la montagne et l'espace de la
guérilla par excellence la montagne
c'est toujours été une zone refuge donc
évidemment c'est un terrain qui est
propice
à l'insurgé parce que c'est un terrain
où une force classique
ne peut pas utiliser complètement ses
armes en tout cas l'effet de César est
beaucoup moins efficace que en zone de
pleine et une opération extérieure a
profondément marqué le retour de combat
en montagne notre engagement en
Afghanistan entre 2001 et 2014 alors
chef de corps du XXe Bataillon de
Chasseurs Alpins le général le naine est
déployé avec ses hommes fin 2008 en
capifa la zone d'opération française en
Afghanistan
alors notre état d'esprit en capital
d'abord c'était
c'est un peu un aboutissement pour nous
tous c'est à dire que
on allait renouer avec une opération
extérieure qui allait se dérouler dans
notre milieu de prédilection puisque la
capitale c'est une province montagneuse
qui est constituée de vallées et qui
était encadrés par des sommets de 3000
mètres donc c'était notre terrain donc
notre état d'esprit c'était
l'aboutissement finalement une forme de
retour aux sources et donc on s'est
entraîné pour ça dans cet environnement
accidenté fait de sommet et de gorge
tous les principes du combat en montagne
ont été mobilisés on était vigilant
d'abord à tenir les positions hautes
parce que celui qui ne tient pas les
positions hautes en montagne que ce soit
au 20e siècle ou au XVIIe siècle se met
d'emblée en position d'infériorité donc
on tenait systématiquement les parties
du terrain avant 5G dans les fonds de
vallées et puis on s'assurait surtout de
nos lignes de communication de façon à
pouvoir conserver notre liberté d'action
son mandat afghan sera notamment marqué
par la bataille d'alassailles opposant
les soldats de la coalition au taliban
de goldine ecmatia
la domination du champ de bataille
l'ubiquité la complémentarité des feux
la préparation aux conditions de
l'engagement c'est la combinaison de
tous ces principes tactiques qui sont
spécifiques au combat montagne qui nous
ont permis de conduire cette opération
avec succès
[Musique]
si les opérations militaires en
Afghanistan marquent un retour du combat
en montagne elles ont avant tout permis
d'asseoir des tactiques éprouvées et
démontrer la nécessité de maintenir un
savoir-faire moi quand je suis rentré
dans l'armée terre c'est vrai que la
gare montagne était un concept assez
éloigné jamais je n'aurais pensé qu'un
jour j'aurais à faire la guerre dans un
pays comme l'Afghanistan jamais je
l'aurais pensé que j'aurais à conduire
des opérations de combat montagne et
pourtant on l'a fait donc
l'enseignement que je tire c'est qu'il
ne faut jamais un jury l'avenir la
montagne a tendance à nivoler la
supériorité technologique parce que face
à l'observation aérienne face à l'usage
des bombes il est relativement facile
pour un homme à pied d'échapper à la
surveillance
et donc si on choisit d'investir cette
cette zone montagneuse il faut y engager
des unités qui soient préparées et qui
soit capable d'accepter de descendre
dans l'arène pour aller se confronter à
cette
à cette opposition
j'allais
directe et les yeux dans les yeux
[Applaudissements]
en pleine nuit cette compagnie de
chasseurs alpins est prise à partie
l'exercice n'a pas officiellement
commencé que déjà les procédures sont
éprouvées
ok j'ai mon groupe qui a été très
réparti au niveau du village
Saint-Antoine trois PACS
du village aux alentours de Modane dans
les Alpes cet exercice de combat en
montagne des marques en bourbattant il
faut réagir vite pour reprendre le
dessus sur l'adversaire et c'est au
terme de deux heures de manœuvre dans la
nuit noire que la situation se stabilise
la zone du hameau sécurisée on a fouillé
les mecs ont du rompre le contact vers
le nord vers la direction ennemie là et
du coup on va on va se désengager du
Havre retourner sur une bivouac et se
remettre en défense sur le qui-vive ces
hommes du 13e bataillon de chasseurs
alpin rejoignent leur temps pour
profiter du peu de sommeil qu'il leur
reste car deux heures plus tard la vraie
mission débute
30 départs premier objectif hameau
Saint-Antoine
objectif à atteindre un fort perché dans
la montagne et pour y parvenir il faut
être le plus furtif possible la zone est
truffée des nuits
en train de se mettre en place sur le
itinéraire pour infiltration
de notre groupe de la section à notre
itinéraire vont se mettre en place pour
pour la suite et c'est quoi la
contrainte de naviguer dans le relief la
de manœuvrer dans le relief physique
forcément les efforts sont plus soutenus
deuxième contrainte c'est que l'ennemi
est sur le haut et on est sur les bas
donc ça nécessite pas mal de
coordination
des débordements enfin des des gros
détours pour essayer en fait de
récupérer justement des positions sur
les sur les hauteurs pour gagner
avantage sur sur l'ennemi dans le combat
en montagne tout est une affaire de
coordination
[Applaudissements]
alors que les premiers efforts ont été
fournis par une section une autre prend
le relais pour toujours gagner du
terrain dans cet environnement éprouvant
300 tu maintiens la plus en face
les contraintes elles sont multiples la
première c'est évidemment le temps en
fait que prend chaque déplacement
puisque c'est évidemment fatiguant c'est
plus long on a des contraintes au niveau
des liaisons radio également puisque
avec les différentes changements
d'altitude il y a pas forcément tout qui
passe on est également contraint par
l'emport en munitions puisque les deux
niveaux positifs et qu'on peut pas
apporter énormément de choses donc il y
a pas mal de contraintes qui s'ajoutent
à ça et donc il y a un vrai travail
logistique qui fait au niveau de la
compagnie pour qu'on soit appuyé par la
section de commandement au fur et à
mesure donc de l'opération on est dans
un dans un terrain qui souvent reste
relativement vierge
et tout ça pour dire que les options les
routes à prendre etc sont pas multiples
donc en fait le terrain non seulement il
s'impose au combattant mais en plus il
n'a pas été préparé ou modelé par la
main de l'homme en tant que tel et donc
les contraintes sont encore plus fortes
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
le combat en montagne c'est un combat
qui se fait aussi au milieu des
populations et des populations qui le
jour où elle choisissent de prendre les
armes sont probablement les mieux placés
pour y combattre efficacement
ok Mathieu tu resteras bien sur la
droite là tu restes bien dans la pente
nous on va se resserrer vers toi
d'accord on va se resserrer un peu sur
la droite
300 m de dénivelé positif plus tard le
fort du sapin il aura fallu 6 heures
pour l'atteindre
entre les deux poteaux électriques
au terme de trois heures d'assaut ces
hommes obtiennent enfin l'avantage sur
l'adversaire retranché dans ses
habitations
si le combat en montagne a
nécessairement évolué au fil des
opérations la tyrannie de ce milieu
reste intangible maîtriser la montagne
ne s'improvise pas et au terme de plus
d'un siècle d'existence les troupes de
montagne n'ont cessé de cultiver leur
esprit cordée et leur savoir-faire bien
particulier pour une finalité faire de
ce milieu un atout pour conserver la
supériorité au combat
[Musique]